Speaker 1: Let's go next to
John from Ohio. Welcome, John.
Speaker 2: I can hear me.
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Okay. Great. Um, I would also like to
talk about the whole gun issue. I was speaking to
my mom about this, and she grew up in the in the
seventies. And she told me, you know, she never
grew up having to experience all of this, all of
these, you know, mass shootings and gun violence.
Yeah. I guess my question is, do you think I
guess can you think of anything that has happened
between that time and now that has really caused
this epidemic to ramp up? I guess maybe besides
the number of guns in our society.
Speaker 1: Well, that's a big thing.
But in addition to that, also just gun culture
here in the United States, guns have become
the identity of many. They have become a valid way
to solve problems for too many people. And that's
that's a factor as well. I mean, it's both the
ready availability of firearms and the flooding
of the market with them and the ease with which
they can be obtained, but also the very toxic and
destructive culture around guns. It's both.
Speaker 2:
Yeah, I agree. I mean, I think I guess it almost
seems like we're a society that just seems to
glorify violence. And I guess maybe that's, I
guess, one other reason to maybe why we see,
you know, the mass shooting epidemic just
ramping up so much in our country. Yeah, maybe.
Speaker 1: To some degree. I mean, the thing is,
generally speaking, the glorification of violence
starts to get into sort of like it's violent video
games that are the cause. And I'm a little bit
hesitant, so I don't know that I would
necessarily use those terms. I like to call it
a culture in which guns are seen as ways to solve
problems that shouldn't involve guns. And that's
just a cultural issue that needs to be changed.
Speaker 2: Right. And I guess by, I guess, a
culture that glorifies violence. I guess
what I mean is it seems to be like maybe
people nowadays are more likely to
be, you know, nice to each other or
be physically violent with each other. And I guess
part of that is, as you said, the idea that guns
are, I guess, an avenue to solve problems.
Speaker 1: Yes,
absolutely. It's a disaster, quite frankly.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree. Well, thank you
for the thank you for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you for calling in.
Lots of folks understandably concerned about
what's going on with guns. That makes sense